mercredi jour de la fête de
l'indépendance de l'ukraine cela fera
six mois que les russes ont envahi le
pays neuf minutes craignant été tué
selon les militaires d'ukrainiens des
dizaines de milliers de femmes se sont
en tout cas engagé dans l'armée
ukrainienne mais les moyens matériels ne
sont pas toujours adaptés mais une
association lance une campagne pour
lever des fonds reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux mélina huet ride à vous à des
robes personnes
choules a été styliste il ya encore six
mois au plus proche de son ancien métier
elle joue aujourd'hui les égéries mais
son uniforme n'est pas qu'un simple
costume enfilé pour l'occasion c'est
celui qu'elle porte sur le front à
égalité avec les hommes nous dit elle
on doit être capable de tout faire
conduire des camions militaires
creuser des tranchées
c'est l'armée
[Musique]
il n'y a rien qui nous protègera doit
être prête à structure
une équité mise à mal par la culture de
l'armée ou les équipements n'ont pas été
créées par ou pour les femmes avec cette
séance photo elle contribue à changer la
donne un pourcentage de la vente des
bijoux qu'elle porte sera reversée asia
match qui cette association l'a fourni
gratuitement en matériel adapté
on a trouvé des mécènes qui nous est
grâce à des dons humanitaires l'un
d'entre eux va acheter des uniformes un
autre va jeter des plaques pour les
gilet pare balles parce que c'est très
cher les casques doivent être plus léger
et plus petit et on ne les trouve pas si
facilement sur le marché
aux côtés de produits d'hygiène intime
ou de sous vêtements l'association ainsi
déjà fourni 300 protection balistique
aux soldats engagés sur le front
ces plaques baisse moins de 3 kg
alors que leur niveau de protection est
similaire à celle que l'armée fournit et
qui pèse plus de 5 kilos
donc ça n'est pas inférieur en termes de
protection
mais c'est deux fois plus léger
mais l'organisation va devoir redoubler
d'efforts dans les prochaines semaines
saignant estime que 50 mille femmes
auront besoin de nouveaux uniformes à la
proche de l'hiver